okay let's kill Hitler let's go kill
Hitler
I think that's will be at least as easy
as this no no I think it'll be much
better if we go kill Hitler
it'll be fine I'm telling you man Hitler
is gonna go down we're gonna eat shoot
him in it's not like each one one nut
you want left you want left nut or right
nut uh I'm more partial to left not like
to be honest I don't know if that's what
you want oh my god I didn't see this
before what I'm a little sad about that
my character's name is Harry Hawker [ __ ]
what a name that that's [ __ ]
legendary what a man jeez I'm the hawk
inist [ __ ] you ever had hocked
[ __ ] yeah yar [ __ ] all right I'm started
to kill to kill the Hitler thing I join
you or whatever yeah do that that'd be
nice friend
all right cool whatever friend man I
don't even have any skills to unlock it
sure would be great to have all these
skills yeah yeah all right you ready
y'all is barf they're a little bit all
right let's change the course of the war
I guess well killing the guy instigating
the bad stuff in the war probably would
change the course of the war pretty
dramatically my problem with him yeah
okay - what an undeserving position for
us to suddenly be in yeah all right
we've done all the hard work let's go
kill Hitler yeah we failed like 19 times
good thing we can respond indefinitely
look we killed like 30 guys trying
several times to defeat that one convoy
wherever the hell that was yeah let's
just do this you know actually we don't
know what we were doing there we're just
kind of like in the middle of nothing
but soldiers okay we don't ask questions
right we just murder
okay all right oh there's another sniper
over there looking at me oh yeah
actually we are red right now I
oh yeah okay Oh file did you just die no
I got hit by the sniper he's gonna get
hit though right at face ah ha ha ha got
him oh I shot at him too I don't know
which one of us did that I got the
slow-mo so I'm pretty sure it was me
probably you whatever oh hi Piper
no oh Lord yeah you okay
oh god I'm bleeding out Lord can't save
you now but I can don't shoot be anybody
knowing shoot me how so much shot
they're shooting they're shooting you
they're [ __ ] you oddly enough they
seem to be shooting me I don't know how
this came to this juncture begin to
think that maybe announcing our presence
maybe standing atop this mountain
shouting she's not cool Vash no what
what what did I just get hit by I
thought I was safe by a sniper I know
there's a [ __ ] guy right over there
I'm gonna get you
here we go you're getting up I'm
providing covering fire I see that very
efficient all right I'm pushing Oh God
wait you were pushing a different
direction than I was
did you try to jump across the chasm I
didn't realize I thought that was like a
bridge all right let's go
all right well artillery is gonna be
down there in the water ah who's behind
us who was over there I don't see an
opening over there point Oh know that
that hurts a lot
well Oh Oh
good to kill Thanks I wish there's a way
to like spot people is that a mechanic
that we're just not taking advantage of
probably I mean I hella imagine it is
cuz that seems like a thing that happens
what was that guy shooting from there
were just bullets coming from a place
and then I looked at that place and then
there was no guy there huh mister here
what's up douche bag what's up [ __ ] how
you like me now I like you a lot I
consider you one of my closest friends
wow that's my god to happen funny dude I
[ __ ] rekt that guy yeah you go time
to move time to move
yeah no joke I'm a heel real quick
Christ Jesus hang out over here hit me
oh god yeah
anyway I'm pretty sure it was my
positive reinforcement that really
really made that shot happen I believe
you all right
good stuff guys oh there all right that
is far away you know don't duck eyes the
[ __ ] I'm gonna push up the bridge a
little bit all right I'm gonna go flail
flail wildly you think Hitler knows
we're coming for him you think he's
aware of this situation if this inside
like having a snack like I do love
apples no one time to kill me
Hitler if I have fun telling you they
have the best apples
why have we not been having these all
the time it's definitely how he sounds
best yeah I'm pretty sure impressionist
spot-on I'm you know first there's no
physical evidence to what he actually
sounded like so it's probably correct
yeah there are no recordings or anything
so is that that the war the Great War
took place in the time before audio so
I'm pretty sure it was medieval times
I'm not it's a hundred cent on that but
I'm pretty sure you actually started at
a medieval times restaurant yeah because
people were fighting over seats because
everyone wanted to be in the Blue
Knights corner
blue line is the best I can't disagree
yeah I actually don't know that much
about medieval times I'm just standing
in the open yellow are you yellow I'm
yellow I was yellow I'm black apparently
uh okay I don't know why I have to make
it like that I'm say you said it was
yellow man so I don't know why you
always have to make it about yourself I
think you did that so whatever you know
what fine just I'm yellow now is that
better
actually that does make me feel better
okay oh that was a pretty long shot why
was that not cool a cool shot you can
get long shots but they're not always
the best
everybody I was pretty proud I mean
seems like we kind of did actually miss
killing Hitler is way easier than
blowing up that convoy or whatever the
[ __ ] we were doing before yeah whatever
that was a question mark Circle what are
we supposed to do here gonna shoot this
bird Jesus the bird just like
disintegrates I just watched it I was
corpse fall slowly into the sea it's
actually quite sad I don't know why I
did that
Hey look a bomb [ __ ] I just watch this
course see my mom there we go is that a
distraction oh why is there a dead guy
in the wall not American
holy [ __ ] Oh American that is not good
I'm going down I don't know if this is
the way we want to go but from above I
don't know why I shouted that but are
you shouting out of ammo reloading right
now I'm not are you Oh dead center in
your gob I appreciate how surprised they
all look whatever whenever it does the
the skeleton view it's always like oh
god I think that's just how skeletons
are [ __ ] oh god I'm about to be our
tiller Road
okay so where are you oh you're down
there okay I'm like I'm Oh what the [ __ ]
I'm coming I'm coming
there's a sniper by the way oh [ __ ] I I
didn't make it from we were fighting the
idiots on the outside part two sniper
force on the inside I think they call
that the SS the super snipers first I
think that was what that stood for no no
I'm pretty sure that's what it is
I was talking oh hey so we're right here
okay so where the [ __ ] was that sniper
at umm I couldn't tell I never saw a
Glenn I just saw oh you're being shot at
and then darkness consumed me oh I got
him in the face oh good shot thank you
it's a guy over there in the distance
but I don't know where he's at I'm not
seeing Mike going the right way I feel
like I'm going a different way suddenly
yeah you're going different way than you
were but hey you do you man so long as
you sniff out Hitler I think that's all
that matters
oh I'm sniffing him mmm that pungent
Hitler smell whoa okay that was oh my
god from behind I don't know man I'm
sniffing Hitler yeah you caught a whiff
oh yeah you got his scent pretty much I
have no idea where this is oh if you
keep going the way you're going you can
go up on that church tower you'd have
like the world's best vantage point that
is exactly what I meant to do from the
beginning dude you're so smart oh god
there's like a placed machine gun here
Oh [ __ ] sake and where is there a guy
in it can I help ya can you maybe snipe
him out a little bit I don't think I got
a there's like big walls blocking me I
fell in a hole
god dammit yeah I've got for some reason
this one's got the Vantage to where you
are blocked I see this guy I'm gonna
shoot the [ __ ] out of him he's climbing
stairs
there's no idea the death there's
nothing I can do about that
that machine gun placement yeah grenades
I'm gonna I tried it I can't if I peek
out even remotely to
I can like see what I'm throwing grenade
at ya I'm just done okay so was it gonna
buy that big concrete thing the machine
gun or something yes I'm gonna keep
moving around this way yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna leave my vantage point I found
the sniper whoa you did on the sniper
he's glinting he's looking at me he's
glinting oh no he's looking at me Oh is
he is he yeah so I could pick up and get
him
no he [ __ ] look Oh God so far you're
so far uh I'm coming buddy
don't you worry I'm gonna make me far
away from it in it
just believe believe in the power of
love believe actually you're not that
far you probably get me just watch out
for that sniper [ __ ] I killed him
it's okay okay good lead what lots of
time once it's believed in the power
love I believe I believe I believe hey
what's up I knew you'd come for me yeah
it was love this cover is not really
large enough for both of us though so
this is kind of a problem oh [ __ ] I ran
out of breath Oh guys tough oh never
mind
oh I shot why do I have an option to
hang here hey I'm just gonna hang here
careful is this like Zelda are you about
to run out of stamina
probably not but I'm gonna climb back up
okay don't know why I did that that's
cool
do you think of it do you happen to have
any extra health packs no hi oh wait yes
I do how do I use it on you though I
don't know if that's possible this is
what think on that that red thing on the
map is the machine gun oh hey we're it's
this big metal box here that we're like
oh so this is a [ __ ] machine gun it's
a jewel box okay so don't go in front of
it don't go in front of it but if I
throw nevermind that bounced off that
will that go inside or no not wait yeah
I got an idea me douche alright so there
was like something place satchel charge
here we go all right guys dad timer oh
never mind okay
adding timer just meant lighting the
fuse apparently
oh no what Tibor means pillbox destroyed
oh my god I just got so much ammo nice
listen to a k47 I mean in mkb 42 yeah
okay that I appear to have an ak-47 now
okay I mean at mkb 42 okay alright I
believe both is a yellow dot Hitler are
we getting close to oh no I don't think
we're close to Hitler no I think Hitler
is inside yeah what a big [ __ ] circle
duty
come over here yeah right here all right
hang on let me do this well that is not
even remotely
I just like hanging off the edge I'm
like okay well that was I just want to
[ __ ] watch the world burn man just
whatever oh this is like a machine gun
sniper rifle if you want that that
exists all right
so in here oh you were above
hell yeah we can totally kill Hitler
from up here Oh
mmm I think this might be where Hitler
is oh is this are we about to totally
kill the [ __ ] I Hitler dude I think
maybe we might that Hitler nah that's
not Hitler
where's Hitler I know sabotage feel safe
and has like places we're supposed to go
well huh try just start spraying with my
gun randomly maybe just for once maybe
maybe don't do that maybe not I mean you
do you hey that guy's runnin why is he
running man what are you in a hurry for
buddy oh is that a sniper oh that's a
sniper you spying the sniper then I'm
spying I'm gonna spread out a little bit
all right cool
see what see where I'm in it see I'll do
it whoa dude it's it's Assassin's Creed
over here it's whatever you just push
the button this is so cool okay so I'm
just gonna stay up here and cover you
from up here yeah I'm kind of stuck now
go down drop down a bit
you got more yellow below you there you
go okay oh geez yeah okay oh there's
[ __ ] guys here so the danger is don't
get dropped I think you have a silenced
pistol use that Oh the fewers on the
move okay wait almost waited guys wait
wait a minute wait and you see them from
wait wait wait
Oh [ __ ] it was already oh my god is
this Hitler this better be Hitler wow
did you just do that [ __ ] killed
Hitler is just straight kill Hitler yeah
oh god they're mad are they real mad
are they angry at us like I did a goof
sorry I shouldn't have taken that shot
yeah we're fine
are we kill all these [ __ ] guys
alright that's fine dig it
oh god I'm bleeding out I think I got
hit by a sniper Oh No
I'll try to come to you [ __ ] yeah I
should have repositioned to cover I was
just like shooting I'm on that okay I
might be a sitting target climbing this
is gonna take forever oh god no no I
should have come back no no no you're
good you're good you're good man
I'm almost there but we kill Hitler I
thought that's the end of the mission ow
oh God we should probably find some
cover
what well I'm over here in cover what Oh
cover yeah that way said I didn't hear
all right where are they at there are a
selection of them to the right cue boom
headshot baby mm-hmm
boom headshot baby yeah baby yeah
[ __ ] Savage man you have no idea dude
I just killed Hitler I wouldn't debate
would you would you kill baby Hitler
what I have to like look him in the eye
while I'm killing him the baby oh did
you see that boat on him sick oh no how
did that it was cool and you know what
[ __ ] I got nothing for you how
about that you know what you just keep
doing what you're doing you seem to be
doing a good job of it me yeah thanks
man you're pretty much holding up to all
what I don't know what I don't know you
see what the bullet was doing no what
did it do it was spinning around on the
surface of his helmet if for me I didn't
see that it was all whoa hey dumbass I'm
[ __ ] directly above you also I'm
above you not [ __ ] I'm just regular
so where are we supposed to go exactly I
don't know oh we have to sabotage oh no
we just have to escape [ __ ] bro let's go
[ __ ] out of here okay yeah what were we
doing murdering people what do we enjoy
it Fox the point of that [ __ ] that's not
the pipe I'm going down this pipe go
back this way down no no no no there's a
pipe see Oh pipe dude but that's not the
way out is it I was just gonna go back
out the way we came escape island is
over here we're going off to escape
island dude oh [ __ ] well jeez I didn't
know that go escape island with you
[ __ ] yeah I'm in all right just whee wow
that's a fun ride I know right you would
kill Hitler slide a pipe it's a good way
to live life
it's [ __ ] best day ever over here
yeah not bad not for Hitler though yeah
you know what I mean yeah on account of
he can't eat food anymore cuz you shot
him in the face yeah yeah yeah I
wouldn't miss food to go just like
jumping in the ocean swimming away oh
wait it's the other platform oops
oh [ __ ] sake [ __ ] trusting you I'm
sorry man how the [ __ ] do we get over
there we have to fight through the main
floor of this thing and just go Oh like
an idiot what are those yellow things by
the way it was just guys who don't know
where where we're at oh those are
totally dudes yeah those are totally
dudes all right I'm coming for you hang
on hang on I'm gonna I'm gonna try and
make it across these boxes over here
that's not a hiding place okay hiding
place we're good man we're good
all right I'm going for a guy yeah we
might want to just try and get the [ __ ]
out of here
yeah I think over here maybe there's
like oh yeah this leads up
uh-huh so sneekybeeky wait
let's don't seem right someone just
yelled murder murder they murdered
Hitler Oh get out the window this is the
escape okay right here dear no well I
mean a little farther away from the
escape but yeah what sir oh never away
whatever we're there
we're the same guy again now apparently
maybe I'm leaving you behind
okay well we go there we go then I guess
[ __ ] easy-peasy
yeah Hitler why Hitler were so much
easier than the rest of that Bush that
was such a big deal oh we didn't locate
the supplies or sabotage any fail-safes
but that's okay guys can you give us
some credit [ __ ] killed the leader of
the axis well I mean I think I killed
Hitler I'm pretty sure you would not
have gotten there without me remember
how you had to keep saving my life
remember that
hey maybe remember how your level six
and I'm level three so I don't that you
taught me about death and that's what
allowed me to have the will to kill
Hitler
that's what it did yes yes I understand
[Music]